bonjour cet homme s'appelle à jean
dujardin a dit john forme de gordes son
âge 25 ans sa mission conquérir les
filles on the beach cet homme s'appelle
bruno salomone wali brunoy - 27 ans et
sa mission s'est séparé que moi en fait
moi ne vous inquiétez pas ça lui
ça va
parfois on sent seul temps vous allez où
là
stable moi aussi j'aime les pattes mais
tu veux pas m'aider à me balader un peu
parce que
ah ouais non ma tante ou du copain tu
peux m'allonger et la surface allen
mais je fais mon favori
sous nicolas dumas même moment
c'est vrai
elle prend le soin et tous on les
connaît moi je réponds si tu veux je te
mettais pas de crème mais un petit peu
ici là pas trop envie de parler là
tapez opinion plus l'affrontement de
parler
je veux moi je pourrais pas par gros
lourd ccsa bon
je peins vas-y shatwan en tous temps
vous avez l'air cool comme ça et
pourtant merde alors je comprends pas
la bâche que je me prends c'est la
première fois en trois ans d'un coup ça
c'est god hand ac je suis complètement
désolé j'y allais à nyala c'est vrai ça
tu aimes pas ça à la bad a fait
dans les cours paulette on s'embrasse
rabiu joue en battant 6-1 80,1 moi aussi
merci voilà
à très bientôt pour la bomba c'est vrai
que la journée a pas été très brillante
bon c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas trop mal et
enfin c'est bien mieux
bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
camping nancy génial mouais gens qui
m'ont petit frère nancy génial mois a du
mal à draguer oui mais juste avec les
filles et l albatros il se sent
maladroit pato inhabiles où elle est
juste avec les filles aujourd'hui c'est
un grand jour pour lui ah ben ouais
car à l'intérieur de ce camping j'ai
caché la femme de sa vie vous sépare
non c'est pas vrai d'accord je ne
quittez pas
bah
surtout
bonjour jean nonnon gens voilà j'ai très
envie de draguer mais non genre il ne
faut pas le dire il faut le suggérer je
peux te suggérer que j'ai très envie de
draguer genre ce que tu fais c'est pas
mauvais c'est très mauvais alors
cherchons toit soit plus poétique
d'accord des yeux sont comme une vaste
valais ou voguer sans vanité de valrhona
in heaven ou ben ça va pas plaire maman
alors fait le strict minimum
mais soit plus comique ne soit plus
tonique toronto tout y est ou
territoriaux theuriau tête aux
constatations
la danse c'est pas ton truc sur point là
t'as quel âge on regarde et écoute
oh toi ma muse un jour tu seras mienne
rejoins moi dans ma tente c'était une
canadienne bruno à mon avis il faudrait
qu'ils soient moins cavalier bon ben ça
c'est pas très bien passé c'est vrai
quoi on n'a pas trop belle pour vous
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la copie non
nous sommes à la compagnie la compagnie
à la mer ouais mais quand même un poil
accompagnons d'accord mais où sont les
femmes
avec leur geste et à nos champs il ya un
problème
justement comment draguer une femme la
mère avec un décor de campagne tout en
sachant qu'ici les femmes sont plutôt
des choses démonstration il ne quitte
pas cette fille me plaît elle est douce
belle et sensuelle et doit très bien
faire les quenelles bonjour bonjour
deniz genre n'indemnise tu me plaît je
te veux il n'a pas vu que c'était moi tu
es très jolie pour la région les stands
des super facile
cette femme ans j'ai bien vu que c'était
bruno il n'a pas vu que c'était moi tu
es très jolie pour la région c'est pas
gagné il va falloir la séduire ici pour
épater les femmes
il faut une super bagnols savoir assurer
sur le mobilier
il faut également l'emmener dans des
promenades bucoliques l'emmener voir ses
copines à l'emmener aux expositions lui
offrir une cuisine qui lui ressemble et
s'intéresser à sa vie quotidienne
et qu'est ce qui fait en ce moment
danese et je te parle se parfumer qui
met notre cologne
[Musique]
écumez rien
à
[Musique]
dubès les femmes adorent senti qu'on a
du blé ta peau cuivrée et aidant à créer
tes cheveux de feu me font frémir mais
non c'est pas crédible
les cheveux de feu j'ai les cheveux
bruns ah merde où la recrue et le
charbon un bon charbon pardon c'est bien
sûr on sait bien sur des charbons bon
bah ça s'est plutôt bien passé
c'est vrai que il a réussi à montaner et
en plus bonjour bonjour salut bonjour
aujourd'hui nous sommes à dove et albert
[Applaudissements]
regard ouais mais pour draguer ici il
faut doubler
bonjour à beauval
il ya une qualité de vie et une
luminosité extraordinaire
tu crois tu vas le faire la vérité pas
ici les hommes sont toutes des pêcheurs
à deauville c'est impossible
le ballet jana chabadabada chabadabada
chabadabada chabadabada
[Musique]
bana bana bana mahmoudi
tu téléphones maintenant du beige la
semaine dernière je suis parti une
semaine sénégal
ouais moi c'est pareil mais mieux
bonjour salut tu sais que je connais
hyper bien le batteur des forbans
bonjour
on entend même
[Musique]
donc tu connais la série l'instit avec
gérard klein abandons on voit un mec qui
passe derrière lui et encore pas à la
base les femmes de salé dans un hôpital
le mans et le club a changé dit il ya de
très très belles choses là tu peux
victimes
je ne puis que ferait un bon ben ça
c'est pas très bien passé c'est vrai que
globalement nous n'avons pas réussi au
ballon enfin on s'est bien marré bonjour
salue aujourd'hui nous avons rendez vous
avec greta et birgit dans un camping
naturiste
autant vous dire qu'on a les crocs f1
mais d'abord il faut passer chez un
vieux bonhomme trop longtemps mais quand
même un petit peu on avait promis on
veut pas longtemps on avait promis
bon ne quittez pas pendant ton premier
voilà à quoi bon ben hammam rival alors
n'a hélas je vous ai fait une bêta ça va
pas changer du tout mais ça c'était pas
trop on serait pas très calme la télé
oui mais alors c'est les vacances
un nom c'est toujours pareil on devait
partir pour aller voir là la région lui
la région il y avait bien sûr de belles
régions à voir et c'est dommage enfin
pour une fois tu peux bien rester un peu
plus longtemps ici enfin je sais pas
pour toi mais moi j'ai déjà mangé ma
famille il ya un moment il faut partir
allez on y va aller vite raymond
il leur tarde déconner surprise de
cahiers des pubs 1008ha qui le mono
elles sont parties à ces morts là c'est
mort je prends la tarte et quinson
parpaings gris
voilà satin tenir compte pour la cour
les enfants je vous ai retrouvé votre
ballon
tenez je promis de rester ici pour fed
est à rejouer au ballon faire la sieste
je n'ai rien à foot avait deux bronzes
est d'une fadeur d'un conflit les coudes
jeune fan f1 même in usa élevé dans les
traditions aussi je lui disais allô oui
alors oui ces deux c'est pour eux c est
un message pour deux jeunes filles
emplacement 4 c'est une tombe john leur
dire qu'on arrivera à 18h 20h mais
pourquoi danseurs de mesquer finances
mais j'en ai marre des tartes
bon bah c'est vrai que ça s'est pas très
bien passé ça c'est vrai on n'a pas du
tout emballé chamailler non non tu m'a
carrément fait chier mais par contre on
la mange et je salue aujourd'hui nous
sommes la nuit ou non mais aussi que ça
sinon bah regarde
ah ouais et qu'est-ce qu'on fait la nuit
en boîte
allez c'est parti les fêtes ont sonné la
sicav sur les négociateurs ce soir pour
ce dessin sur la piste de danse
ces partis ne buvait pas bonjour je peux
rappeler la boîte était combien jeu tout
seul fait accompagner
quelques jours
bonjour jeter dans la boîte et combien
je suis en effet près la même période ça
va
[Musique]
j'ai même thème est après l'arrivée
avant le déjeuner à midi aura façon
inverse
je n'ai pas derrière ça sent pas avec
toi et moi d'argent des saisonniers ici
l'eau à savoir les eaux chaudes les
garçons car son retour de m shia de la
boîte à bazar est là qu un cheval de la
bonne bataille
pourquoi d'actionner la bande à basile
au cm2 les eaux chaudes salées tant
qu'île je pense à moi moi lavabos
robinets
je te penses quoi toi tu as bien ses
tentatives il est alors la fille vierge
et vilaine après que six en catimini le
dividende qui s'est investi chez qui le
fils christian ce master
attention ces masters choix dans son bon
sens
alors tu as et moi ça ne se passe pas
comme ça ici sur une fille tu me donnant
l'autorisation verbale inventif devant
lui alors est ce que seront livrés chose
que je veux moi l'expression mais on se
ressemble et je te lance un défi sur la
pelouse hier bon c'est vrai que ça ne
s'est pas très bien passé c'est vrai que
moi j'ai pas franchement emballé on
vient de lancer aujourd'hui mon badge
aujourd'hui le bonjour vous pouvez me
prendre un réel plaisir
sympa elle est grave comme monde
en tout cas c'est très gentil merci
justin prix jean luc non genre là les
verrous comme ça j'allais dans une
auberge de jeunesse vient chez moi c'est
opère chaque 11 aces je crois qu'on va
bien s'amuser tous les teints tintin
[Musique]
tu es mon autre circulent ici à ta guise
mais ne tarde en tueur jamais dans la
chambre bleue c'est d'en faire ici il ne
croit pas si bien dire
tintintin asie profite de la vie am
histoire suis ici chez morts c'est très
gentil mais d'où vient cet homme il n'a
pas vu que c'était moi à bien y regarder
comme c'est étrange je m'amuse et
pourtant cet homme me fait peur vas-y
régal toi mais ne va jamais dans la
chambre bleue
tintintin
mais pourquoi tant de mystère autour de
cette chambre bleue qui parles-tu à un
copain réalisateur fabien lucifer
lucifer fabien saluant chanter tu fais
comme chez toi
vous n'êtes pas dans la chambre bleue
tin tin tin
greg renault voici ta punition mais pas
plus haut à prendre le soir l'arrêté no
wave et des palais dhabi ouais c'est
vrai que ça s'est plutôt bien passé ça
on va super mais emballé enfin le
problème c'est qu'on a rêvé or qu'est ce
qu'on fait on va y retourner un jour
elle est aujourd'hui nous sommes à la
recherche de doses à bassan c'est quoi
badie des femmes alors oui mais elles
sont sauvages maggie femme sauvage
oui mais amazon ça peut faire après
l'accord in ta comprennent pas tous pas
de mal notre mission les localiser dans
l'écosystème c'est quoi la nature
vanille la nature alors oui mais qu
systèmes 100g train comme une pas
compris j'ai perdu un petit peu de
balles et qui ont tendance à santa rosa
à pilatus pire acteur black hat airlines
s'est abîmé dans la mer démontée un
salon à son bord deux pour la famille
princière de la principauté à salinas de
la course donc survécu à la catastrophe
que les deux filles et cadettes de sexe
féminin cachot et vanessa ne quittez pas
atteint
un marché durant deux jours ça des liens
il n'avait qu'un seul objectif
tu m'as dit alors que l'avion s'était
crashé en 71 points donc elle devrait
avoir 26 ans regarde mes restes de
l'appareil
ça se trouve à sont à l'intérieur du
rebond au menu sarah shourd ce nom en
chemin ils ne croisent air que des
cageots il nous avait fait faux
il avait soif et faim mais ils avaient
leur jeu fin à cela il me rend fou je
n'ai plus la force et bruno rejoint le
côté obscur a rejoint le côté obscur
rabat vient là il ya moins de soleil du
mal à lemieux l'a beaucoup mieux soudain
ils aperçurent un bruit ces femmes on a
bien vu que c'était nous
une marche air durant des jours et des
lunes c'est un double ça se trouve
l'avion se serait crashé en 1926 à leurs
prêts donc 71 ans au bon ben ça c'est
pas trop bien passé
c'est vrai qu'on s'est carrément trompé
d'année enfin on s'est bien marré on
voit en bois salue aujourd'hui on rentre
à paris non c'est non c'est non ça va
bon reste à la mer ouais mais quand même
un peu d'accord mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire un pari gagné des sous mais
pourquoi faire partir en vacances on y
est déjà
ah ouais n'hésitez pas
t'en a pas marre de le filmer taka
bérard de nous poursuivre partout l'a
déjà les vacances ça suffit maintenant
cette vidéo tu as dit on rentre on tadic
rentrée bon tu nous lâche encore la
toile bon tu as dit nous lâcher là c'est
bon on a vu qu'on était plus drôles les
plus drôles à terréal possible était
trop fatigué e un we no way
voilà en route à gagner plus drôle alors
voilà et genre quoi j'en vois tu as une
tâche là un rôle normal on arrête de
nous bouffer un petit bouton bêtisier
bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
temps non bonjour un jour bonjour le
vent soufflait les femmes adorent le
sport est affiché bonjour salut tu sais
que je connais hyper bien le batteur des
forbans tu vois la série n 1 0 qui
s'ébat
je m'appelle jean bruneau non mais
bonjour jean un non non bon ben sahar
est qu on s'est un peu coffret vous a
pas tout compris mais par contre j
accueille maintenant alexandra lamy et
jean dujardin
et
c'est un triomphe enfin c'est incroyable
alors vous êtes pour ceux qui ne savent
pas encore vous êtes les héros de un
gars une fille qui prend un petit
programme de sept minutes diffusé depuis
deux ans sur france 2 avant le 20h
et c'est vrai que les présentateurs du
journal télévisé valls sur france 2 mais
vous vous êtes toujours là chaque soir 5
millions de téléspectateurs suivent les
aventures de chouchou et loulou un jeune
couple que vous incarnez qu'ils sont
ensemble depuis sept ans lui c'est vous
ouais vous êtes plutôt machos 15 aigner
dragueur jaloux tendance infidèle
colérique fans de foot et de bagnols 1
c'est vous vous êtes coquine coquette
pipelette accro au shopping et au sexe
oui jalouse mais tendance fidèles vous
voilà oui alors le programme dont le
collège est une succession de petites
saynètes entrecoupées d'un habillage
très chouette très très branché 1
la série est issu d'un concept québécois
mais elle explose dans tous les pays
d'europe où elle est adaptée
alors évidemment pour ceux qui
connaissent pas on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble mal et lozère signifiant quoi
tu me fous la course au contrat
qui regarde ma femme la mort
le débat sur les retraites afin de mieux
les filles sexy y aura des campings
ajoie non je trouve pas
si les vacances
un gars une fille
si on prend
fusion
pour déminer alors alex est né à alès
oui vous rêviez temps petit de devenir
gardienne de chèvres
oui c'est marrant quand vous savez ça
oui et puis ensuite formation de théâtre
classique au conservatoire de nîmes et
en 92 vous débarquez à paris pour des
auditions vous commencé le théâtre les
téléfilms vous êtes évincée du casting
d'un gars une fille départ à cause d'un
mauvais partenaire pour redemander une
chance et cette fois c'est jean c'était
un père il a dit à la productrice
c'est une nana qui pourrait me faire
donc ça c'était décision
[Applaudissements]
enfin
ouais il a dit isabelle camus sol à
prendre parce qu elle vraiment j'ai
envie de me l'a tapée quoi ça c'est le
chinon genre mais à rueil malmaison
après le bac et le service militaire
deux ans serrurier dans le bâtiment oui
ça apprend la vie ça non ouais ouais
gcs des comics en bâtiment le mic en
bâtiment et le soin one man show dans
des cafés théâtres et puis membre de la
bande du carré blanc est là un jour
jean dujardin a déniché par stéphane
calvet le directeur artistique de
l'émission vous faites graines de stars
way et vous gagner trois fois de suite
ouais c'est vrai j'ai le record chaque
fois vous verrez plus jamais ça et vous
vous y retournez quand même ouais c'est
vrai c'est super souvenir quoi c'est
vrai c'était fabuleux
super pétoche mais bien content mais
c'est là on s'est rencontré d'ailleurs
la voie là et on va voir avec des fois
vous avez gagné
[Musique]
salut salut
sa femme sa forte ça farte bombe
welcome sur la plage de lacanau beach je
me présente je m'appelle brisse julien
de nice de nice tu sais comme elle
m'appelle les familles six mois le
sniper
je suis harcelé la journée je me cache
dans la baraque à frites obligé de surf
et la nuit à la bougie
mais la nuit c'est les sirènes qui me
gonfle non attendez attendez je veux
dire c'est dur d'être un canon je le
souhaite à personne
en plus moi le style blondasse plastique
féline et je vais te dire ça me laisse
rêveur
f d'ailleurs si une pitchouns dans le
groupe un peu raboteuse qui aiment le
gac
rendez vous ce soir en campine et
vaniteux emplacement de l demande brice
le roi de la glisse alors là vous
décidez avec avec vos copains de
l'époque la bande du carré blanc de
créer une troupe de faire les lignes
c'est nouveau et qui fait ça
c'est
[Musique]
il est même
caresser
les nous c nous trouver
beaucoup d'émissions de télévision des
parodies sur france2 d'ailleurs souvent
est alors en 99 il appelle camus la
productrice et le pense d'abord à josé
garcia pour un gars une fille puis voilà
il était pris par le cinéma et c'est lui
qui a suggéré votre nom ah bon ouais
c'est ça c'est vrai mais c'est bien sûr
c'est vrai que j'y allais à reculons
départ
ouais parce que j'étais en train de
repeindre la chambre de mon fils et puis
moi les castings s'est pas fait sans pas
super bien que moi donc
elle m'a appelée puis elle m'a montré
les les vidéos des canadiens donc et
puis ça m'a plu
vous avez vu cinq filles et puis la 6e
c'était alex ouais ouais ouais ouais
puis c'est passé tout de suite enfants
nous ont vite délivré même débit un
grande complicité tout de suite
finalement il fait ce qu'il dit en
parlant de vous et c'est mon pote avec
des seins en attendant même temps c'est
sympa et pas ça voilà justement alors
j'ai des problèmes avec vos conjoints
respectifs
il paraît qu il vous embrasse plus
souvent que votre jules c'est pas vrai
bon c'est thierry ardisson
mais qui va tenter d'organiser un dîner
1 c'est vrai oui on s'est rencontrés
pourquoi il a fait un dîner avec ses
deux coups pour être sûr qu'il y avait
pas la fed en tout cas 4 quoi c'est
rigolo
je salue ou après après toi tu as
rejoint
on est sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu